how many rehearsals do you have for a
japanese concert uh
it depends on the event but we do all
definitely we do a lot of rehearsals
beforehand and we'll do like like before
the shows um we go through like
it's called genipro but it's a
rehearsal where you do it exactly
like so basically just a dress rehearsal
the yeah the show
exactly how it's done and you probably
need to do that two or three times
audio so when you perform a concert
you're not just performing it once
you're performing it like four times
exactly in secret most of it when it's a
big big bad [ __ ]
the last time that counts
going back like a million topics going
back to the
exactly i'm really intrigued about the
whole anime opening you know process
how do you so from complete start to
finish like how do you get the like call
where you're like hey
this is a show it needs an opening how
does that all go and then how does the
process go like you
you write it you know i just want to
know everything about it because i feel
like we haven't actually like yeah yeah
talk about the process to be a waste not
yeah i think it depends on the artist
but um if you pre if you're like uh
signed with
an anime-based label yeah then
there are a lot of like types that need
uh
artists so they're always looking for it
and it depends if
you are the one that sort of offers or
they offer for you
it depends on the situation but once you
sort of uh get an offer or you
get a you go grab an offer then
that sort of starts into the songwriting
creation and then
you write all of it yeah you have to
make it from zero usually
okay so um that begins there and i wrote
all the lyrics for my
songs not all the melodies but um all
the lyrics
do they give you any input on any of
that like they're animated do you have
like any source material do you
write around that or is it just usually
we start writing when
the series isn't um complete yet so we
only get like
a really brief um description so what
was it like for something like patoom
what do they say just like
oh batoon was actually a manga before
the enemy so that really helped
she's gonna read all the manga you read
the manga and you
sort of uh they also have hints like
this kind of song or that kind of song
and then um you try to fulfill their uh
expectations there but batum for example
no pain no game
we had a lot of freedom with that song
right so uh they
really probably didn't expect that kind
of sort of
up upbeat and so uh but everyone really
like
so it stood out in a good way i think it
stood out and
um they were like wow we weren't
expecting this in a good i mean
i think i can speak on behalf of the
anime community being like
most people if not all people only
remember the opening
so so is that like a a one take here's a
song i'm done or is it like they
constantly are always
like can you change this can you change
this can we try this sometimes um
they have very like uh
detailed sort of descriptions for what
they want but sometimes it's just
completely free
so with batum though uh we had a lot of
freedom so we didn't have to
adjust or redo a lot of things but for
other songs for example
there are a couple of um uh
retakes or uh recreations or something
there are some songs that i've done i've
i've written
that have completely disappeared okay
right
right so when you do an anime opening
who who owns the rights
to that song is it the did the anime
people just get like a license to use it
in the anime and you retain everything
or like how does that work
if you know it might be the label right
that's probably
the label has the song right and so um
when the song is used
the the rights belong to the leader
because i think flying dog was like it
can correct me if i'm wrong it's like a
major label that
was primarily focused on like more anime
music so like
a lot of like anime like osts and like
openings were usually
started and owned by that record label
so like um i like how you're looking at
connor like he's gonna know what you're
talking about
because i was always interested in as
well of like how i guess like
rights and like distribution works for
anime songs because i feel it's
completely different to like an artist
just
releasing their own yeah i always wanted
because you know a lot of the songs
wouldn't have you know wouldn't blow up
without the animated back of it so i
wondered if there was a system that like
there was like co-ownership or like
i'm just pretty intrigued i didn't know
if you knew yeah it's very complicated
like the rights thing is just
is it just sounds like a nightmare yeah
like youtube issues with like rights and
it's always a mess yeah you know
in japan everything about the rights is
huge you know like you can't say
certain stuff on tv yeah um you you need
permission for a lot of things yeah
we've experienced that so
japan [ __ ] do you have permission
hell
it's just like never-ending the approval
chain is just
[ __ ] a mile long i never like there
are so many things
it's like since working with japanese
companies did i notice
i was like oh you needed approval for
that because it was the first time
um that i had that i experienced like
taking off
a label off a water bottle
drinking in front of media in america
i never even thought about that yeah i
openly drink heavy on water
so you know like taking the labels off
like
at events or like that is completely
japanese
culture right i noticed that the first
time actually when i was watching like a
japanese tv show and i noticed that
the water bottle on like the desk or
whatever was like
mosaiced out and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are they drinking
[Music]
how bad is this is this hentai water i'm
drinking like lolly water i've seen this
i mean they'll show you shots on tv and
it'll be like shibuya
everything is blood yeah except for like
two people walking yeah
why are you even showing this just i
don't
it's odd because then two seconds later
it'll cut to a shot where everything's
shown and i'm like
there is no consistency on this i'm so
confused
you know there must be some rights going
on where it's completely flip-flopping
and uh yeah i don't know it's bizarre
how did it feel like the first time you
watched an anime and just
heard yourself singing before the anime
started oh
it was really nerve-wracking um i was
probably
peeing my pants because you're
pretty much living the dream that i
think a lot of like especially like
western weebs one where they're like
yeah i can sing one day i'm gonna sing
in an anime opening
like it's very surreal it's very surreal
it didn't really like hit home until a
lot later
yeah because do you i assume when you
are producing the song you don't
actually get to see
the animation opening of like what they
put to your song first time that well
actually i did see like a
a sample of the opening but the first
time i actually saw the official like
finalized version was on tv right so it
was probably like the same as you guys
yeah right i was like in front of the
screen i was like what the
hell what the hell is happening
i hear my voice from the tv you normally